pas question de reculer des dizaines de
manifestants de partout en catalogne
marche vers barcelone romain schaal
talla cheese pâtes
il arrive un moment où l'étincelle
s'enflamme c'est inévitable dix jours
dit il y à toutes les injustices que la
catalogne oui nous en sommes au point où
le coeur peut faire plus que la tête
l'ambiance est bon enfant entre les
chansons de résistance de l'époque de
franco et un repas partagé la colère
porte un sourire mais elle n'en est pas
moins profonde surtout chez les jeunes
certains ici ne se reconnaissent pas
dans la violence et le saccage dont
barcelone et le théâtre ces derniers
jours
vous pouvez voir que ça c'est pavillon
lèvres ça c'est la fête dans la
démocratie
mais d'autres comme maria crois que la
mouvance plus radicale de certains
manifestants toujours minoritaire c'est
peut-être la seule façon d'obtenir
justice
systar a déclaré dallas il y à des
exagérations dit elle mais on en est
arrivé à ce point on a besoin de faire
ça sinon on n'obtiendra rien on y
restait pacifique et il se moque de nous
cette crise provoquée par l'arrêt de la
cour suprême espagnole condamnant des
figures indépendantistes catalanes à des
peines allant de 9 à 13 ans de prison se
prépare depuis longtemps croit le
professeur de droit cha bière bosse en
catalogne il y a eu des politiciens qui
n'ont pas agi comme si le droit n'existe
pas et à madrid
on a eu des politiciens qui ont agi
comme si la seule chose qui existe est
serait le droit il n'est pas davantage
rassurés parce qu'il décrit comme l'
attitude de confrontation systématique
du président catalan actuel kim torah
qui promet un nouveau référendum d'ici
deux ans
avec la nuit tombe et l'ambiance festive
de la journée a été remplacée par une
fois plus des incendies de la violence
la peur et les menaces ne nous vaincront
pas dit le président king tu auras
aujourd'hui après avoir condamné cette
nuit pour la première fois les violences
des derniers jours
dans quelques heures c'est le début
d'une grève générale décrétée par les
syndicats en grève générale qui vous le
voyez s'amorce dans un climat toujours
prétendu les marcheurs pour la liberté
ne sont pas seuls à converger vers
barcelone et les manifestations
des renforts policiers aussi sont en
route en prévision de l'imposante
mobilisation ici marie ève bédard
radio-canada barcelone